Let's make some lasagna from scratch.
It was a gloomy day outside,
so what better way to spend it
than cooking a comforting meal?
I started off by making my mozzarella cheese.
I added some milk,
citric acid
and run it to my pot,
let that sit,
and then sliced it all up,
transferred my curds to a cheese cloth
to let all the way drain out.
That sit for about five to 10 minutes,
and then when all the way was drained out,
I added it back to the pot with my heated up whey
and stretched it.
Once it was shiny and smooth,
I formed it into a ball
and placed that in some cold water.
Then I made a really simple pasta dough with some eggs,
flour, olive oil, and salt,
kneaded that until it was all smooth,
and then wrapped it in some plastic wrap.
Tub rest for about 30 minutes to an hour.
My favorite part of cooking any meal is chopping.
So we started chopping up some carrots really finely,
some celery,
and some onion.
You can use purple onion or white onion.
I just love a good purple onion.
And then I brown my meat in my Dutch oven,
add my vegetables,
some tomato paste,
some crushed tomatoes,
and some herbs.
I let that simmer for about 30 minutes to 45
while I prep my lasagna sheets.
I cut my dough into eight pieces
and then rolled them out into rectangles.
When it Was about time to assemble.
I made a quick bechamel
sauce to go in between my layers,
and then started putting it all together.
I put down a layer of the ragu,
some bechamel,
then my lasagna sheets,
and then kept repeating that until I reached the top.
At this point,
I took my mozzarella,
sliced it up,
and layered it on top.
I decided to only do one layer,
but feel free to add any other cheese that you want.
And then I popped in the oven for 35 minutes
and pulled it out,
and it came out so perfect.
But since I couldn't wait,
I burnt my tongue with that first bite.